not everything you see in movies is real
but it's hard to fake chemistry or is it
these co-stars prove that you don't have
to actually like someone to convince the
world your bffs what's a little lag
licking between friends you'll have to
watch to the end to find out
during the filming of the fate of the
furious there was an alleged beef
between two of the film's biggest stars
vin diesel and dwayne the rock johnson
just like in life you have different
philosophies and people have different
philosophies different fundamental
philosophies on how you do things and
again the most important thing is just
the movies after the production johnson
took to social media to praise only some
of his co-stars writing in a
sense-deleted post
my female co-stars are always amazing
and i love them my male co-stars however
are a different story some conduct
themselves as stand-up men and troop
professionals while others don't
although it was unclear exactly who the
rock was referring to the aim of that
jab most likely included diesel diesel
addressed it to clear the air telling
usa today i don't think the world really
realizes how close we are in a weird way
i think some things may be blown out of
proportion in my house he's uncle dwayne
allegedly ryan reynolds had trouble with
wesley snipes during the filming of
2004's blade trinity but then again
apparently so did the entire cast and
crew journalist chris perry who at the
time was working on an article about the
production of the film spent some time
on the set and spoke to crew members
anonymously one source talked about
snipes and reynolds relationship saying
he refers to ryan reynolds as that
or teldec to get out of my eye line and
tell that to get his lines right snipes
reportedly was difficult with everyone
on set and there have been rumors that
he even at one point strangled the
film's director david coyer according to
the hollywood reporter goyer never
confirmed the incident but he did say
i have tremendous respect for wesley as
an actor he used to be a friend we're
not friends anymore i don't think anyone
involved in that film had a good
experience certainly i didn't
2000's charlie's angels was a box office
hit bolstered by a star-studded cast
that included cameron diaz drew
barrymore and lucy as the angels and
bill murray as the pseudo-manager bosley
however in reality the team didn't seem
as connected as they did in the movie
the story goes that there was a rewrite
of one scene and murray wasn't happy
with it for some reason he took his
frustration out on lou despite her
claiming not to have anything to do with
the changes she addressed the incident
during an interview on the los angeles
times podcast asian enough according to
lou murray began insulting her and she
didn't back down she said i stood up for
myself and i don't regret it because no
matter how low on the totem pole you may
be or wherever you came from there's no
need to condescend or put other people
down the two have seemingly rekindled
their professional relationship but lou
still thinks she did the right thing in
standing up to murray
it's hard to pinpoint the exact reason
for the long-standing feud between sex
and the city co-stars sarah jessica
parker and kim cattrall but it's clear
that the two weren't the best of friends
on set in an interview with piers morgan
cottrell explained why she didn't want
to return for the reboot series saying
she had been portrayed as demanding or a
diva in the press she also singled out
parker's behavior is that i think she
could have been nicer
i really think she could have been nicer
i don't know what her issue is tensions
escalated later when after a death in
the family catrol posted a message on
her instagram directed at parker it read
your continuous reaching out is a
painful reminder of how cruel you really
were then and now let me make this very
clear if i haven't already you are not
my family you are not my friend so i'm
writing to tell you one last time to
stop exploiting our tragedy in order to
restore your nice girl persona at the
same time parker has maintained that she
never had it out for control saying to
elle
i don't think anybody wants to believe
that i love kim i adore her i wouldn't
have done the movie without her
one of meryl streep's first starring
roles was alongside another current
veteran dustin hoffman in 1979's kramer
vs kramer ann streep claimed to the new
york times that hoffman went too far
while filming the incident happened
during a scene in which hoffman's
character slapped strips and apparently
the slap was a little too real referring
to the scene streep said
this is tricky because when you're an
actor you're in a scene you have to feel
free i'm sure that i have inadvertently
hurt people in physical scenes but this
was my first movie and it was my first
take in my first movie and he just
slapped me and you see it in the movie
for hoffman's part he did admit that he
was difficult to work with during the
production and that his problems in his
personal life affected his co-workers on
set
although they teamed up on screen jim
carrey and tommy lee jones weren't quite
partners in crime on the set of 1995's
batman forever and much of that
animosity came from jones according to
carrie there was one incident that spoke
to jones feelings about him during an
appearance on the late norm mcdonald's
talk show carrie explained that during a
day off while filming the movie the two
happened to be sitting in the same
restaurant carrie decided to go over and
say hello which apparently wasn't
something jones wanted he went like to
hug me and said i
hate you
i really
don't like you carrie then asked what
the problem was and said i pulled up a
chair which probably wasn't smart and he
said i cannot sanction your buffoonery
of course as the riddler carries
character came with a certain amount of
buffoonery but apparently the man behind
the green question marked jumpsuit had a
little too much silliness on set for
jones's liking
marlon brando and sophia loren starred
alongside each other in the 1967 charlie
chaplin directed comedy a countess from
hong kong according to loren brando got
a bit too touchy-feely and she responded
by letting him know that was not okay
she explained in her autobiography
yesterday today tomorrow my life writing
all of a sudden he put his hands on me i
turned in all tranquility and blew in
his face like a cat stroked the wrong
way and said don't you ever dare to do
that again never again although brando
didn't do anything like that again while
filming the movie it made the rest of
the production uncomfortable for loren
she admitted that it was difficult to
work with him afterwards
gene kelly's singing in the rain co-star
debbie reynolds revealed that the
twosome's working relationship was more
fraught than their on-screen report she
wrote in her memoir he came to
rehearsals and criticized everything i
did and never gave me a word of
encouragement reynolds continued that
when it was time to shoot the kissing
scenes with kelly things got even more
uncomfortable writing
gene took me tightly in his arms and
shoved his tongue down my throat oh what
was that i screeched breaking free of
his grasp and spitting and to make
matters a bit more awkward reynolds was
just 19 at the time while kelly was 37.
reynolds went on to write i was an
innocent kid who had never been french
kissed it felt like an assault
behind the scenes of 1983's terms of
endearment there were rumors about how
tension between shirley maclaine and
deborah winger manifested on set in some
very strange ways during an appearance
on watch what happens live winger was
asked about rumors that she tried to
pass gas towards mclean or that she
licked her leg while the latter was
trying to film a love scene with jack
nicholson was any of that true you mean
you want to just go in there and say is
there something true in there yeah
there's something true despite the
fighting the duo of acting great still
holds each other in high regard at least
professionally with winger telling the
new york times i can't deny that we
fought but i think there was always a
respect between the two of us the grudge
match between hollywood icons betty
davis and joan crawford is so legendary
that it was turned into a tv show in
2017 aptly titled feud betty and joan so
what was the issue well a lot of things
the two reportedly fought over nearly
everything including lovers movie roles
fame and parenting all before ever
working together it all came to a head
when the duo start alongside each other
in 1962's whatever happened to baby jane
entertainment weekly writes that davis
once said
the best time i ever had with joan
crawford was when i pushed her down the
stairs in a scene in which davis was
supposed to fake kick crawford in the
head she actually did make contact and
it resulted in three stitches but
crawford got her revenge during a scene
where davis had to pull her out of bed
crawford secretly wore a heavy
weightlifter's belt under her costume
knowing that davis had a bad back
even when crawford died in 1977 of a
heart attack the fight lived on upon
hearing of her rival's passing davis
allegedly said you should never say bad
things about the dead only good joan
crawford is dead
good
kenny baker and anthony daniels better
known as their iconic characters r2d2
and c3po respectively weren't as close
as their iconic on-screen bond made it
seem baker has publicly said that
daniels disrespected him on set by
calling him insulting names daniels
responded to the claims telling his side
of the story in 2019 to the daily
express saying kenny decided that he
wanted to say unkind unpleasant rude
hurtful things it got worse and worse
when the suits came on however it was
all business and easy to put aside their
differences daniels explained the fact
is we didn't really appear or interact
together he was in a box he couldn't do
anything with he couldn't hear me he
never made a sound
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite on-screen partners are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]